[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle saison de mode
d'emploi votre magazine consacré à
l'emploi et aux formations
professionnelles pour ce premier numéro
focus sur la ryder cup tout de suite le
sommaire c'est le troisième événement
sportif le plus suivi dans le monde de
la ryder cup 2018 se déroule à saint
quentin en yvelines du 24 au 31
septembre une opportunité économique
pour le territoire
près de 7000 personnes travaillent au
golf national durant la semaine de la
ryder cup agente de sécurité ou de
nettoyage vendeur ou encore hôtesse
d'accueil
les entreprises spécialisées dans ces
secteurs recrutent pour assurer leur
mission lors de l'événement à la fin de
ce magazine retrouvez vos rendez vous de
l'emploi dates horaires et lieux nous
avons sélectionné deux événements
organisés au mois d'octobre et sur notre
plateau nous recevons deux invités erwan
le gall vice-président en charge de
l'emploi et à l'insertion à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines bonsoir choix et oujda ounissi
directrice général d'absys agency
entreprise basée à montigny le
bretonneux spécialisée dans l'accueil
événementiel bonsoir ça alors avant de
nous pencher sur la question de l'emploi
des emplois créés pour la ryder cup
je vous propose de regarder ce reportage
sur les principaux chiffres de la
compétition mondiale de golf un montage
signé xavier jallais du 24 au 30
septembre la ryder cup s'installe au
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines trois jours de
compétition opposant les meilleurs
golfeurs européens et américains trois
cent mille spectateurs sont attendus sur
le green avec un accueil quotidien de
70000 personnes près de 750 millions de
téléspectateurs vont suivre l'événement
une compétition diffusée à la télévision
dans 185 pays
un coup de projecteur sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
les retombées économiques devraient
dépasser les 100 millions d'euros des
grands groupes seront présents lors de
la compétition comme air france bmw ou
encore société générale
de quoi faire valoir l'attractivité du
territoire
durant l'ensemble de la semaine près de
7000 personnes employées pour
l'événement seront mobilisés au golf
national dont 4000 postes ont été créés
par l'organisateur ryder cup europe
alors à roanne lequel on le voit dans
ces données économiques et puis aussi de
création d'emplois la ryder cup c'est
une source de visibilité pour saint
quentin en yvelines mais c'est aussi une
opportunité pour créer des emplois tout
à fait alors même si le le délai court
parce que c'est une semaine mais en
amont et en aval il se passe aussi des
choses mais on sent bien aussi que
derrière ça certaines personnes
prétendent et attendent aussi autre
chose
au delà la ryder cup où il ya des vraies
retombées économiques et c'est un vrai
vrai levier pour l'emploi très
clairement quel type de contrat ils vont
être signés là pour pour cette semaine
en fait c'est des contrats courts
évidemment mais derrière il peut comme
je disais récemment il peut y avoir
aussi une ouverture pour des cdd plus
longs voire des cdi
voilà mais en tout cas ce qui est
important c'est de voir l'engouement des
gens demandeur d'emploi des jeunes qui
sont aussi peut-être vacataires ou en
attente d'autres choses venir
s'intéresser sur différents postes et
secteurs d'activité pour répondre aux
besoins et derrière aussi peut-être
susciter l'envi dans un secteur
d'activité et puis aussi pour d'autres
mais écoutez deuxième change troisième
chance pour repartir
je les ai entendus encore récemment un
monsieur qui dit aimer écouter
j'espère être pris puisque derrière pour
moi c'est un remettent le pied à
l'étrier et en plus ce n'est pas quelque
chose de dense dire que c'est une
semaine c'est bien pour moi c'est un
vrai équilibre
voilà où je donne unis si c'est votre
cas est ce que les personnes que vous
allez embaucher alors je précise vous
recherchez 150 hôtes ou hôtesses
d'accueil pour la ryder cup est ce que
c'est le cas ce qui est vainqueur à
roanne le gall est ce que des personnes
que vous allez embauché pour la ryder
cup vous allez peut-être les conserver
peut-être en cdd ou d'autres types de
contrats après cet événement
tout à fait c'est exactement le cas on
recherche là pour le coup pour la
semaine de la ryder cup du 24 au 30
septembre 150 hôtes et hôtesses et
effectivement les personnes qui vont se
démarquer sortir du lot pourront être
retenue pour d'autres événements ou pour
de l'akr entreprises notamment donc des
postes en cdi
alors 150 hôtes et hôtesses d'accueil
pour la ryder cup
on va voir s'afficher à l'écran la fiche
les caractéristiques des personnes
recherchées donc on voit que c'est des
personnes dans jeunes plutôt homme ou
femme ça vous étés galerie nom puis deux
hommes et femmes jeunes ou même un petit
peu moins jeunes mais ensuite des
caractéristiques
des compétences professionnelles
certaines donc une bonne présentation
d'abord un certain sens du service
professionnels motivés ponctuelles et
puis l'anglais est un plus l'anglais
notamment parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
visiteurs étrangers qui vont se rendre
sur la ryder cup et en lequel vous avez
accompagné plusieurs entreprises dans
leurs recrutements dans les communes de
saint quentin en yvelines notamment dans
la restauration le commerce la sécurité
le service de nettoyage ou l'accueil
d'après les chiffres des services de
l'agglomération c'est près de 1000
postes qui ont été ouverts dans ces
secteurs
comment avez vous travaillé avec les
entreprises pour préparer cette ryder
cup préparer au recrutement alors
préparez au niveau des entreprises de 50
ans divine je suis tenté de dire c'est
assez facile puisque on a un lien en
permanence avec des entreprises c'est
reconnaît quant à une agglomération
ultra dynamique sur le développement
économique donc on découvre pas les
entreprises on est dedans entrailles a
vécu en permanence donc ça c'est pas été
un gros problème
l'autre point que l'autre va dire
difficulté mais c'est les accompagner
dans des séances de recrutement hockey
de betting genre de choses mais c'est
surtout des secteurs d'activité ou
nationalement c'est des secteurs qui
sont en tension je pense l'hôtellerie la
restauration
donc là il a fallu mettre le paquet pour
sensibiliser un certain nombre de public
pour permettre au moins d'avoir un panel
de gens nés de le décrire parce que
c'est valable pour les hôtesses mais
ceci est valable pour la restauration
parce que il ya ceux qui cuisinent mille
ceux qui servent
et puis être bilingues ils l'expliquent
service je crois que l'esprit de service
et énormément important à double titre
parce que l'événement
le préconise et appelle par rapport aux
sports à être dans cette notion d'esprit
de service et puis surtout l'esprit de
service et pour l'après coup c'est à
dire que on va être vu mondialement
pendant une semaine
donc si déjà à la base on n'a pas cet
esprit de service
ça va transpirer au travers des
télévisions donc c'est vraiment
important
donc j'ai un peu digresser par rapport à
votre question mais pour revenir c'est
que on a vraiment accompagner et puis on
a on a quand même un service très
puissant au niveau de l'agglomération
avec des contacts a donc on avait des
référents dans chaque entreprise
et puis des liens en permanence
téléphonique mais il paie et consorts
quoi comme le dit erwan la ryder cup
c'est vraiment un événement mondial
qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous
abscisse agency alors pour nous déjà on
a l'habitude de participer à de nombreux
événements sportifs et notamment dans le
domaine du golf on a on a participé à
l'open de france en juin dernier
essam enfin four les organisateurs
savent où ça leur a permis de tester sur
l'événement et pour le coup oui c'est
une très belle référence pour notre
agence pour avis à vienne ici ça va
entraîner des dégâts importants
oui c'est pas négligeable
après au sein d'absys donc on est on
fait là qu'un d'entreprises et de
l'accueil événementiel
on est à 70% sur de l'accueil en
entreprise
et puis à peu près 30% sur
l'événementiel mais oui la ryder cup va
avoir des retombées importantes pour
nous alors poursuivre nos échanges à un
forum de l'emploi spécial ryder cup pôle
emploi et saint quentin en yvelines ont
organisé une matinée de recrutement pour
la société clean event france cette
entreprise aura en charge le nettoyage
des structures du golf national pendant
la semaine de compétition
un reportage de grégory canali ils
veulent apporter leur contribution à la
ryder cup
une trentaine de personnes a participé à
la matinée de recrutement de
l'entreprise clean even france une
société spécialisée dans le secteur du
nettoyage notamment pour les grands
événements sportifs
les structures sont assez bas 9 a monté
spécialement pour l'événement notre
mission à nous bat sara de maintenir les
les structures en bon état et enfin pour
l'accueil du public
donc on est rentré en contact avec
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et le pôle emploi afin de
d'avoir un vivier humain de staff qui
habite pas loin de l'événement cette
entreprise mobilisera près de 180
personnes par jour durant la semaine de
compétition
ce matin là elle est venue recruter 150
collaborateurs en contrats pendant la
semaine de la ryder cup une chance je
fais pas fait suivant le recrutement et
vu que l'accès pour que cadiou - du
kansas a peut être bon mais ça peut
peut-être se relancer sur un autre
projet ce vivier humain qu'on recrute
aujourd'hui bas reste dans notre base de
données on est très très susceptible
d'être rappelé pour les événements
d'après parce que même vis-à-vis de la
région d'haillicourt en garde l'open de
france
quel évènement moindre comparé à la
ryder cup mais quand même qui n'est pas
cassée considérable et qu'on utilise 80
personnes au lieu des 180 sur une ryder
4 pour les candidats retenus après avoir
rempli les documents la création d'une
accréditation est obligatoire pour avoir
accès au golf national et contribuer à
leur manière à la réussite de la ryder
cup à saint quentin en yvelines
alors où je donne ici comment vous êtes
préparés justement à recruter pour la
ryder cup
comment ça s'est passé les contacts sont
faits comment les contacter pour la mise
en place de la ryder cup
oui alors c'est pas notre premier
événement avec cet organisateur donc
voilà on a on fait beaucoup d'événements
autour du golfe notamment ce que je vous
disais l'open de france qui a eu lieu en
juin dernier
et puis pour le coup juste après l'open
11,6 me organiser la ryder cup avec eux
à mettre en place le nom d'hôte est
souhaitée les différents postes
ou est-ce qu'elles seraient affectés et
à tout un travail de qui a été fait
depuis juin dernier déjà alors vous
recrutez toujours les 150 hôtes et
hôtesses d'accueil
si vous souhaitez qu'on est candidate et
pour ces postes vous pouvez envoyer
votre cv et votre lettre de motivation à
recrutement @ apsys agency.com l'adresse
mail s'affiche en bas de l'écran
erwan le gall pour conclure comment vous
allez attiré travailler pour attirer de
nouvelles entreprises sur le territoire
durant la semaine parce qu'on sait qu'il
va y avoir beaucoup d'entreprises
étrangères mais aussi françaises qui
vont venir voir le la ryder cup
comment vous allez faire pour vendre
l'attractivité du territoire pour
peut-être créer des emplois après nous
avons des très bons commerciaux à saint
quentin
non mais nous avons des experts et je
crois qu'on n'a pas grand chose à
prouver sur de notre territoire
donc on garde innovations on a on a un
stand qui est située sur sur le site de
la ryder
des grands comptes seront présents
maintenant commerciaux et aux services
d'avico de faire leur job mais aucune
appréhension par rapport à ça ça ça va
se faire naturellement
après c'est un moment clé certes qui va
passer une seule fois devant nous sur
d'autres territoires
mais il faudra regarder et accompagner
dans le secteur après les faire revenir
pour le faire visiter nos grands joyau
de du territoire voilà et juan ogalla
nonis et merci d'être venu sur notre
plateau avant de refermer ce magazine
noter dans vos agendas plusieurs
rendez-vous pour l'emploi on commence
notamment avec l'opération coup de pouce
pour un emploi le mardi 2 octobre de 14h
à 18h au scarabée de la verrière
c'est une participation sur invitation à
obtenir auprès de pôle emploi la mission
locale skywave 16 25
la cité des métiers où les services de
vos communes pour plus d'informations
rendez vous sur le site ew rencontre
égalité emploi.org autre rendez-vous
l'événement emploi se tiendra le jeudi
18 octobre à l'espace saint quentin
toute la journée vous pourrez venir
rencontrer des responsables dans saigne
du centre commercial ils recrutent des
personnes dans le secteur de la vente de
la restauration et de l'optique
si vous souhaitez obtenir plus
d'information vous pouvez consulter le
site internet www.cinematheque.fr c'est
la fin de ce premier numéro de mode
d'emploi merci de nous avoir suivis si
vous souhaitez revoir cette émission en
replay vous pouvez vous rendre sur le
site internet ou sur notre application
mobile merci et on se retrouve le mois
prochain pour une édition consacrée aux
métiers de l'automobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
non